Embrace artificial intelligence this one
you may have heard about it maybe not
friend it is here to stay it is real and
it's kind of scary artificial
intelligence may not replace you but it
should assist you
so HubSpot says that video has the
highest Roi of any media by far and
Adobe says that the average user now
watches 19 hours of video content per
week so I'm so excited because in this
think media podcast I'm gonna be
breaking down my 2023 YouTube trends and
predictions for creators and business
owners and I've got 10 of them and this
is going to be not really just like
Could Happen far out their predictions
but there's going to be some tactical
strategy in this episode so buckle your
seatbelt because we're really going to
go deep and unpack a lot of actionable
insights so you can get more views get
more subscribers and grow your channel
this year but today's episode is brought
to you by think media sale we're still
doing 75 percent off of our YouTube
starter kit and our Niche Finder course
all of that's in the show notes and I'll
tell you a little bit more about that
later but let's dive right into number
one which is go all in on vertical video
so HubSpot says that short form video
will see the most growth in 2023 and I
think that we can all agree with that
sentiment YouTube shorts Instagram reels
Tick Tock Facebook reels Pinterest
vertical video yes I was on a trip to
Israel and uh one of the creators on the
trip with me showed me his Pinterest
account and he said hey I've made
thirteen thousand dollars in the
Pinterest vertical video beta program
and I was absolutely shocked I was like
Pinterest is a place where you pin
recipes what do you mean they're doing
video now essentially Real Sports and so
vertical video is blowing up and it's
time to go all in
it is the most effective and it has the
highest return on investment this is
what a lot of the data in my predictions
and Trends are pulled from Adobe HubSpot
top marketing firms with a lot of
research behind them and when they
measure the return on investment the ROI
of vertical video what they're measuring
is the fact of how hard is it to create
and how much reach can you get how many
views and then how much business can you
drive or results and so vertical video
is technically the easiest to create and
it has the most
opportunity for virality
so ultimately investing in vertical
video is really smart Adobe said short
form video accounts for 80 percent of
all mobile data traffic right now and
short form video is also good for your
brand you can produce more content in
less time plus viewers are more likely
to engage with shorter video that gets
straight to the point so when you're
doing short form right YouTube shorts or
you're producing vertical videos at your
place you're posting multiple places my
real estate agent and real estate
investor friend of mine Anton is short
form video has allowed him to enter the
content game he hasn't really cracked
the code on live streaming he doesn't
really make one to make long form but
he's using just his phone no fancy
microphone he's creating vertical videos
and he's posting them as YouTube shorts
he's posting them as tick tocks Facebook
reels and Instagram reels and he's like
it's crazy the ROI is already coming in
and they're not super hard to create the
constraints are helpful because it's
vertical in less than 60 seconds I'm
able to also post it multiple places and
so ultimately investing in short form is
a big deal and if you're not subscribed
to the think media podcast yet on
YouTube or audio wherever you listen to
it definitely subscribe because we're
going to be bringing you more content
about vertical video YouTube shorts all
year long but one of the tips that I
don't necessarily agree with although
it's worth stating here on number one is
Adobe said in 2023 Brands need to keep
their video content to 10 minutes or
less
now I don't agree with that because
we've seen especially on YouTube they're
actually being a huge opportunity for
really long content two hours two and a
half three hours we'll touch on that
later but I do agree with it in the
sentiment of
attention spans or shortening and when
possible if you can trim the fluff
short form video is shortening attention
spans and I think that the expectation
on longer form video we should take note
so unless the content needs to be longer
and there's a purpose for it when in
doubt
trim it down shorten your content that's
a huge Trend and one of the predictions
number one is vertical video it's going
to be the most growth it's here to stay
let's go to number two
Master the Eight Second mindset so
getting attention fast is more important
than ever and one of the terms even from
some of the employees at Google is the
rising demand for snackable Content now
I did this as a whole separate point
because while this might sound similar
to Vertical video as being short form
snackable content the Eight Second
mindset applies to
everything it applies to your longer
form videos it applies to taking your
hooks more seriously than ever before
now by the way some YouTube short stats
YouTube shorts now has 1.5 billion
monthly active users and sees more than
30 billion daily views making it a big
opportunity for advertisers and that's
uh think with Google quote
so snackable content shorts is rising
but also thinking about
grabbing people's attention so a tip
here is people in 2023 are not
interested in short or long intros we've
been talking about this a lot though I
think this is not a new trend but it's
like your intro should be less than five
seconds possibly one to two seconds ours
here at think media is you got to just
press record
that's it and I have it on a soundboard
right next to me on my rode uh podcaster
but that's the whole intro you gotta
just press record with a camera noise so
people they want to get straight to the
point the way you should be opening up a
video podcast
a short a reel should get straight to
the point your video should get straight
to the point we got to trim the fluff
and so mastering the Eight Second
mindset the people who win on YouTube
the people who went on social media are
going to master the Eight Second mindset
attention spans are shorter and don't
just apply that to short form content
apply that to all of your content number
three start your video podcast so Adobe
said the great podcasting boom has
already happened but the sector is still
growing every year in fact U.S consumers
listen listen to 15 billion hours of
podcasts in 2021 podcasts are also an
incredibly effective way to drive sales
at sixty percent of listeners report
searching for a product after hearing
about it on a podcast so podcasts in
audio are already a major Trend but I
think even deeper than that if you
haven't heard yet a document leaked from
alphabet which is the parent company of
Google and YouTube talking about their
plans for podcasting they hired a
full-time executive to oversee
podcasting at YouTube
you can go to youtube.com forward slash
podcasts and see a page aggregating
video podcasts and other stats showed us
that actually YouTube is the largest
podcasting platform meaning it actually
gets more listens AKA watches but
listening time than Apple and Spotify
which makes sense because if it's just
the JRE Clips or the Logan Paul
impulsive show or h3h3 podcast or
Patrick davidvalutainment Lewis house
school of greatness all these different
podcasts a lot of people go to YouTube
to listen to them and YouTube is
infinitely bigger than Spotify and apple
in terms of podcast listening so all
that to say is that the intelligent
YouTube Creator is going to be thinking
about starting a video podcast now they
may pull in RSS feeds to YouTube
for the audio side but we say video
podcast here at think media because of
the opportunity to not just be on
YouTube and have it be searchable but
also and discoverable and clips from it
but also that you can distribute it
across audio and this is why a couple
years ago we started the think media
podcast and this trend just continues to
rise it's not too late to get in the
game it's not too late to start a video
podcast we will be talking more about
that this year a lot whether you should
start a separate Channel keep it on your
main Channel all the different
strategies with it
Omar El takori is kind of a resident
think media expert on video podcasting
we'll be bringing him on the show but
number three is start your video podcast
number four Embrace artificial
intelligence this one you may have heard
about it maybe not you might think it's
hype you might think it's weird friend
it is here to stay it is real and it's
kind of scary Embrace artificial
intelligence means that every smart
YouTube Creator every business owner is
going to realize a couple things one
artificial intelligence may not replace
you but it should assist you it may not
replace one of your team members but it
should be embraced by every one of your
team members so if you haven't gone to
chat GTP yet which is at openai.com
we'll put it in the show notes and
there's some good YouTube videos out
there it's pretty scary you can go to
chat GPT and you could say write me a
script for a YouTube video comparing the
Sony zv1 and the Canon M50 what's
shocking is it'll write you like a 501
word script with the megapixel out with
the flip out features like incredible
detail its conclusions may be wrong
about which one's Superior or whatever
comparing them after it finishes writing
you could say can you make it longer
it'll add more detail you could also say
do this in a chatty voice you can give
more distinctions to it and so I
encourage you as homework after this
podcast or or just something to open up
on another screen it's free you can go
to openai.com sign up and start playing
with this tool but as far as like
writing scripts
and is it going to replace the quality
that a human can do I don't believe it
will but it's potentially going to be
able to help you save 70 of your time
doing the heavy lifting on the script
then you go on and add your voice but it
goes deeper number four is Embrace
artificial intelligence vid IQ if they
haven't dropped it yet publicly already
has a description tool so you just write
what your video is about the kind of
title or just the basic keyword long
tail keyword phrase that your video
covers and it'll write you a two three
four sentence or three paragraph short
but like keyword Rich optimized human
voice description for your YouTube video
just so it better indexes in Google and
it's a description of what you're about
to talk about you can change it really
quick it happens in a second and if you
don't have vid IQ
um you can check that out at vidiq.com
forward slash think there's a whole
Suite of tools that vidiq gives you they
also have their AI title generation tool
they're using AI to help you with with
daily video ideas but it goes deeper
there's a software called gilacloud.com
and it'll help you generate videos from
news content social posts live sports
events and statistical data in minutes
and so it's AI there's AI video editors
and AI is also in things like Adobe
Premiere there's an AI color match tool
there's a morph cut tool this might all
sound a little bit overwhelming but a
couple things you need to hear first of
all take a deep breath second of all
realize we only have probably about
three to six months left before the
machines kill us so we might as well
Live It Up why why we have time
and then third of all realize that
artificial intelligence is here to stay
and
you gotta skate to where the puck is
going not even to where it is it's time
to get educated in 2023 about how these
tools can help you go further faster
about how they can be added to your
workflow about how they could be
integrated into your workflow I really
actually don't think they're going to
replace as much as we as we think
however I would argue they'd say okay is
AI going to make my job irrelevant it
could but the reason it'll make your job
irrelevant and you'll get fired is if
you're not using AI because AI can make
you 20 30 40 60 more effective the
person who doesn't learn the new tools
is going to be at the mercy of the
person who does and maintains their job
because they double their productivity
because robots are working for them and
the skill set to develop is the ability
to ask better questions
to still be a Visionary and be able to
visualize the final product the final
YouTube video that you want to make and
really the skill set to direct is you're
going to be more the symphony director
so you're the conductor at the symphony
so you might be filming the video
yourself but you directed chat gbt to
help you write the script you modified
the script a little bit you did an AI
thumbnail generation the thumbnail of
this podcast on YouTube is an AI version
of me and so you but we still had to
creatively think through okay what was
the best one we didn't just randomly
there were some really lens that did
some terrible
um AI versions didn't even look like me
my hands growing all weird I did a I did
a carousel on my Instagram of it you
still have to be the DJ you have to be
the conductor of the symphony you still
have to be thoughtful in terms of your
description but instead of you taking 20
minutes to write your description you're
taking two seconds to have vid IQ write
it for you and then you're taking one
minute to proofread it you just saved
yourself 19 minutes
so number four is Embrace artificial
intelligence and um is uncomfortable
that as that make you feel change is
hard it might feel weird it's here to
stay and uh something to lean into all
right number five
adopt the media company mindset Transit
predictions you are a media company the
brands that succeed the businesses that
succeed and even the solo creators that
succeed are Solo creators who stop
dabbling and they start dominating and
take the mindset that I am a media
company so you are a media company Adobe
said it this way you aren't just a brand
you're a media company and an influencer
too so you shouldn't be treating
content creation is or you should be
treating content creation as a separate
wing of your business with its own
Revenue generating opportunities so I
know a lot of our community here on the
think media podcast you want to go
part-time or full-time on YouTube as a
Creator as a personal brand great you're
a media company so you stop thinking
like a solo Creator and a solopreneur
and you think about how am I building a
media company if only it is you as the
conductor CEO of the media company vid
IQ works for you chat GPT works for you
vid chops works for you on some video
editing you have a personal assistant an
admin assistant that's a VA eventually
you're still the boss you're still the
CEO and you're still thinking bigger
but especially if you're a business
owner an entrepreneur or a brand you're
not just the thing you do you're also a
media company
and by being a media company in a
Content company you also have the
opportunity
to create new Revenue generating
opportunities like it actually can bolt
on additional income streams for the
Creator the YouTube Creator and
influencer primarily these are your own
these are your primary in income streams
but for the business you becoming a
media company it's kind of like if
you're a brick and mortar restaurant
you may not start a YouTube channel
and actually drive more local sales or
people coming to your restaurant because
of the YouTube channel what you may do
is use your kitchen on the off hours
with some lighting and a camera and you
doing cooking videos to create a one two
three four five thousand dollars a month
and AD Revenue Cooking Channel that's an
extra that's pure profit besides your
hustle
because you already have the recipes in
the ingredients and the restaurant
so you just added on a whole new
advertising income stream because of
creating YouTube videos and tapping into
the ad Revenue partner program and then
as you know and again we'll talk about
all of this at length here on the think
media podcast I encourage you as the new
year starts and it's still kind of a
slow time right now go through our
library and look at some of the titles
and topics that stand out to you
especially about monetization there's
just so many Revenue generating
opportunities the punch line is number
five adopt the media company mindset and
another Point under this is one of the
brands predicted that influencer
marketing this was like HubSpot will
continue to grow in high Roi now it's an
interesting time
truth is that as we're kind of in this
weird somewhat recessionary period you
do have some a lot of bigger influencers
are saying
that their brand deals are slowing down
or getting canceled because Brands and
maybe big tech companies are being
productive protective of their ad spend
they're backing out of some brand deals
now it's all subjective true but
subjective because I'll tell you this
that think media our brand deals have
not slowed down brands have not been
pulling back we have not had canceled
contracts but it depends on the industry
I suppose
but here's what HubSpot predicted over
one in four marketers currently leverage
influencer marketing and IT offers the
second highest Roi of any Trend so
here's what they're talking about for
you the YouTube Creator or the
individual with the YouTube channel only
one out of four marketers so the CMO of
a company
are actually embracing influencer
marketing more will continue to embrace
it so if only 25 embrace it now what
happens when 50 75 100 you're the
beneficiary of that because more
businesses that want to sponsor more
creators just means there's more money
in the system and so the key for you
though is I want to encourage you think
like a media company
is your Media Kit ready are you
positioned for Brands to be able to
reach out to you have you positioned
yourself
to be the beneficiary of small
businesses and bigger businesses that
want to work with you the other
prediction that HootSuite a HootSuite
article talked about is that small
businesses will be teaming up
with small creators
because smaller businesses you've
everybody's seen ads of Squarespace
you're listening to a podcast purple
mattress you're listening to you know
nordvpn we've seen that brand Deal on
YouTube videos right but
small businesses will start embracing
influencer marketing now we're in
prediction territory and I and I would
agree with this so small businesses
start embracing influencer marketing you
have a small Channel
they see the opportunity to drive Sales
Drive sales to their e-commerce site but
you have to be findable you also have to
be on the offensive of finding these
businesses I think there's an
opportunity to even consider working
with smaller businesses in your local
community filming for them making ads
for them Biz Dev with them bring them on
the show collaborate with them the
mindset here's number five is adopt the
media company mindset you're the CEO
what is your this is your brand deals
influencer business Partnerships
division you are partnering with
businesses you're attracting small
businesses that want to hire you you're
thinking about your Media Kit you're
thinking about your pricing you're
thinking about your deliverables I mean
I can highlight your product in a video
I can make a commercial for you I could
make a video of your local business I
could like you think about pitching
yourself and think about the revenue
opportunities in terms of influencer
marketing and that was one Trend that I
wanted to highlight was that small
businesses will be teaming up with small
creators so get ready for that and also
be aggressive in building out your media
company and that's another theme we'll
continue to talk about here and one
other piece of this was also that a
prediction was long-term brand
ambassadors and we've been seeing this
at think media six months to 12 month
brand deals even two years then one
video and one ad placement I think it's
smart because it's more efficient it's
also smart that rather than just
constantly being sold to the highest
bidder which we'd never recommend but
it's not just ad spots or commercials
it's looking for like Partnerships
long-term brand ambassadors if you if if
we know we love the product like vid IQ
if we know we love the products and we
use the product and the product
continues to evolve and we can get
behind it and we would wholeheartedly
recommend it to our friends and family
without being a brand partner with them
then they would make a great brand
partner because we would recommend it
anyways and so that was one know if that
is one of our partners really and it's a
brand deal it's a brand sponsorship but
it's long term and we are brand
ambassadors for vid IQ and it's a
win-win-win-win-win because we recommend
it anyways it's cool that we can work
with them we have an affiliate
opportunity we're also compensated on
top of that we integrate it into our
content that's across the board this
video is not even sponsored by vid IQ
forward slash think but I'm shouting
that out or just letting you know about
it just because we talk about them on an
ongoing way all right so we have the
next five tips but uh I hope you've been
getting value and I'm curious which one
did you like best which one stands out
to you most today's episode as a
reminder is brought to you by
thinkmediasail.com there's a few more
days left I believe January 5th is the
end of our 75 off sale on our YouTube
starter kit and our Niche Finder course
super great price I think it's 47 right
now huge discount I mean Niche Finder
alone is normally a 200 program if you
want to get dialed on your channel topic
for 2023 plus you want to get our best
bundle of downloadable templates for
titles our title guide our video ideas
list our 51 money making ideas guide our
thumbnail create awesome thumbnails
training and all this different stuff
that's all in the starter kit those two
things at a steep discount are ending
soon and so check out the show notes
thinkmediasail.com
and if you want to start or grow a
YouTube channel in 2023 if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel definitely check that out and
let's get into number six number six
live streaming is here to stay so this
is not really a new trend or a new
prediction but here's what the stats say
according to one report consumers spent
around
548 billion hours streaming through
mobile devices in 2021 that was the
newest that I found in regards to one
just it's a couple years ago so the
numbers are higher two that's just
mobile devices so we know this is huge
in gaming but this is also huge we live
stream all the time I think media you
may have already started to embrace live
streaming
um are you considering embracing live
streaming in this new year here's one of
the reasons
um live streaming gives you the
opportunity to connect deeper and it's
real time so it's really you I want to
encourage you to make sure you're
subscribed because the next episode of
the podcast is kind of the part two of
this and it's sort of a different angle
on my Transit predictions I think it's
going to be one of the most important
episodes I ever talk I share with you
because it's three YouTube tips that if
you ignore them you'll regret it and one
of them is just on the need of
vulnerability and transparency we've
seen so many like cryptocurrency rug
polls where people been scammed nft
scams from Big influencers click bait
like people going for just like quick
money but dishonoring Their audience or
highly polished content creators that
say one thing but then something comes
out that's not really you know who they
are
so the thing with live streaming is it
really just puts you out there so
there's a lot of reasons but that's just
one reason to highlight is that it
connects deeper and it is real time so
it's really you it's really hard to fake
anything for over time on live streaming
because you're just out there as opposed
to the fact if you can hide behind
editing or you can hide behind a filter
the power of live streaming is it really
connects and my point is one of the big
trends which will unpack much more in
the bigger in the next episode is this
idea of people overly polished content
is just not going to win in 2023 more
vulnerability more authenticity more
real more raw and live stream is one of
your opportunities to do that I think
also multi-streaming and we talk about
stream yard a lot I'm recording this
podcast on stream yard
um that's another one of our big
partners because it just gets better and
better if you want to check it out
stream with think.com is 14 day trial
They just added perfect record so I'm
actually recording this video podcast at
a higher quality it captures to my hard
drive first gets uploaded to the cloud
then I'm able to just send that link to
an editor and boom this podcast is Off
to the Races just recording it from home
so stream yard is an incredible tool but
when streaming which I'm just recording
that's not live but when streaming you
of course cannot just go to YouTube but
you could go to multiple Facebook pages
twitch if you want to rtmp streams so
basically anywhere and you can
multi-stream so it's just an opportunity
that live streaming is here to stay and
to maybe summarize this point as we get
ready for number seven you also saw that
YouTube evolved to now organize their
content better and if you haven't
noticed on channels lately they now have
a videos tab a shorts Tab and a live
streaming tab so my prediction for 2023
is that the Savvy YouTube Creator is
going to be embracing all the different
content formats strategically on brand
for their Channel serving their audience
understanding Their audience but
embracing the different content formats
I also want to encourage you if that's
overwhelming you don't have to do them
all at once but as you move maybe from
part time to full time develop and
sharpen your skills and get one percent
better with every upload you will see us
modeling at think media that we're doing
longer foreign video podcasts we're
doing YouTube shorts we're doing live
streams we're doing edited videos of all
kinds of different links it's a it's a
multi-media format World in
2023. number seven join the SEO Revival
SEO stands for search engine
optimization I would argue that SEO
never went away but what's been
interesting about the last couple years
is that it's kind of been forgotten
about and a lot of people have thrown
the baby out with the bath water
understandably when it comes to YouTube
the shorts shelf which is not search
based is a place to go viral with shorts
the suggested and browse features
traffic Source on YouTube is the place
to go viral being recommended by YouTube
and a lot of people have ignored search
engine optimization but what's
fascinating is I was just talking to one
friend who said he was building a PC and
he was looking at every part of his PC
that he would look up to study was a
YouTube short that ranked in search I
heard Gary vaynerchuk talking about the
opportunity of using of ranking YouTube
shorts now our core program at think
media our main course is called video
ranking academy and our students have
continuously seen success as of we with
ranking videos and creating search based
or intent based content so of course
it's not just YouTube shorts it's also
long form video it's also making your
your content discoverable and findable
it's also realizing that your videos can
rank on Google but here's some 2023
things to consider one prediction was
voice search tactics for SEO businesses
are responding by changing how they
frame information to answer readers
questions based on intent creators are
opting for more conversational question
and answer formats this way when
consumers use voice search they'll get
high quality accurate responses more
quickly so how you optimize organize
your content has an opportunity to get
discovered as people are using voice
search and you need to be aware that
people are saying you know hey Google
hey Alexa hey Siri and I hope my phone
doesn't come alive right now but they're
they're saying that and then how are
they verbally framing what they're
looking for you have a chance to get
discovered in that regard right for
people before you write for search
engines so I think what we're seeing
with the SEO Revival is it's not SEO
being revived the way it used to be done
you gotta know the way it's done in a
2023 world yes you want to understand
keywords and you want to understand
keyword phrases and you want to
understand viewer psychology and all of
the above but the key is you also want
to write for people before search
engines another huge key to SEO in 2023
is you want to become an authority on
the topic so Authority is one of the
things that Google is always valued and
Google owns YouTube it's not talked
about a lot but Channel Authority
matters on YouTube so Channel Authority
is that YouTube eventually figures out
oh think media talks about cameras and
Tech a lot and people respond with that
okay if they just randomly post a
gardening video besides the fact that
that would be disaligned with the
viewers that we're not an authority on
that so your goal is to strive to be the
best resource on whatever topic you're
discussing and then know this 79 of
consumers care about content
trustworthiness so seek to go deeper in
a place of authority when it comes to
search engine optimization or video
search engine optimization and then also
focus on your click-through rates and
engagement metrics which would be modern
ways of what ranking means like on
YouTube it's CTR and avd on top though
of a good title good thumbnail and I
know I'm throwing a lot at you the
summary of number seven I mean we got a
year of amazing content for you you know
Lock and Load to to ride or die with the
think media crew on the podcast but SEO
is not just here to stay but it's really
the SEO Revival
time codes and chapters on YouTube is a
whole opportunity for ranking on the
first page of Google in regards to key
moments there's a lot of stuff that we
can go deeper on on but I want to give
you the final points number eight
understanding audiences the Creator who
wins in 2023 understands Their audience
the best and so here's a couple
recommendations go beyond basic
demographic information it's crucial to
know their interests and hobbies how
they like to shop where they consume
media the online communities they are
part of the challenges they face and the
social causes they care about do you
know that stuff about your audience that
might be worth rewinding this part of
the podcast and to think about that
again because uh that's the kind of
information that you want to know not
just demographics but psychographics
psychology the Creator who understands
the viewer best wins and Adobe suggests
this that empathy and human focused
content will win in 2023. so lean into
relatability emotions and empathy that's
the key to building real connections
with your followers nearly 95 percent of
consumers are more loyal to brands that
are transparent and genuine and 75
percent would pay more to support
genuine Brands Adobe found understand
your audience empathize feel what they
feel think about what are their problems
and their Ambitions and the truth is
this is kind of marketing 101 but as we
think about 2023 trends like this is
crucial now like you can't afford not to
be in tune and into touch with what is
keeping your ideal viewer up at night
what are their worries what are their
hopes what are their fears what are
their problems what are their Ambitions
are you speaking to those problems and
those pain points are you empathizing
and relating with where they are where
you're helping them go on your YouTube
channel huge key to success in 2023
number nine e-commerce will continue to
grow why is this a big opportunity
because e-commerce is you as an online
entrepreneur or who's building a media
company this is your opportunity to
monetize whether it's through affiliate
marketing an e-commerce sale needs to
happen which simply means an online sale
whether it's you eventually creating
your own products that'll be e-commerce
whether it's you partnering with DTC
direct to Consumer Brands that's
e-commerce so for that brand to be able
to afford to pay you they need to have
good sales so if e-commerce is not
growing we're all in trouble in the
crater economy but it is growing so
here's the stats according to a research
completed by emarketer online retail
sales will reach 6.51 trillion by 2023
with e-commerce websites taking up 22.3
percent of total retail sales it might
shock you that the number is that low so
they're saying that maybe by the end of
the year we're going to hit 22.3 percent
of e-commerce when it comes to retail
sales but what that means is that really
for everybody buying things only two out
of 10 are shopping in e-commerce you
might about spit out your coffee and
fall out of your chair because you're
like Sean I order everything online what
do you mean not shopping online at all I
mean there's other things I buy but as
far as me being a part of the e-commerce
game I'm definitely in the two out of
ten I think what's important to notice
is that 8 out of 10 have not like really
embraced e-commerce yet but the amount
of growth we've been seeing tells us
this two years ago only 17.8 percent of
sales were made from online purchases
and so basically we're seeing
double-digit e-commerce growth now put
this in perspective I've been doing this
thing since 2010. I've been full-time
since at the end of 2015 I was full-time
freelancing in 2015 full time in 2016.
originally just from Amazon affiliate
commissions off of e-commerce sales and
it might have been 11 or 12 percent back
then of total e-commerce and I'm making
a full-time living allow around with
tens of thousands of other creators
today every number is multiplied but
here's the good news we have we're not
even close to seeing the maturity of
e-commerce of video platforms so Sean
summarize I got you the good news is
while it may feel like there's a lot of
competition and while it may feel like
it's an uphill battle to grow your
channel and grow your income this
industry is just getting started this
next decade is going to be the best
decade on YouTube If Only 2 out of 10
now by the end of the year are shopping
online what happens when it's 4 out of
ten double these numbers and your
position now building your media company
building your channel positioning your
brand putting out good content learning
new skills to be in front of the wave so
the wave of money comes crashing down
upon you and you just have more money
than you know what to do with I'm not
trying to Hype you up I'm trying to give
you data to just show you that you're
still positioned at the early stages of
an industry the crater economy continues
to grow small businesses only one out of
four marketers are embracing influencer
marketing so again what happens when
it's two out of four three out of four
and you're not just sitting on the
sidelines but you're actually in the
game taking action leveling up your
skills learning and developing and
positioning your brand learning online
marketing learning online branding
understanding positioning you're
positioned to capitalize on e-commerce
self and one of the things that's also
interested about this is just a more
marketing term is a new term that I I
read about called hybrid Commerce
Commerce so what I'm also not
insinuating nor is anybody else is that
e-commerce is going to replace in-person
Commerce of course there's certain
things we still want to go shop for it's
hard to buy candles online because you
can't smell them and so I think that the
evolution of the online influencer the
online Creator partner with the brand
getting a brand deal maybe doing
affiliate links someone may be
connecting with your content but doing
having an in-store experience just
something as far as a little bit of
predictions and future casting what
hybrid Commerce is talking about is
decreased distinction between online and
offline that's sort of the evolution of
the space but all of that to say
e-commerce continues to explode in
different nations I know we have a
global audience here on the think media
podcast and thank you for being a part
of our community from just around the
world and of course not just in Canada
or the US e-commerce is a little bit
further behind in certain areas and
growing more I spoke in Panama at an
influencer conference once and got to
talk to people were like man it's still
early here Brands though are just
starting to kind of wake up to what
we're doing affiliate marketing is still
developing I think what you can be
confident in is that you can bet on all
of that still growing you can bet on all
of that being an opportunity that people
are going to Trend towards what has
happened in the U.S and whether it's one
out of ten shopping in e-commerce then
it's two out of ten three out of ten
four out of ten and you want to go all
in now in 2023 so you could be
positioned to ride the wave I've got
number 10 for you in just a second we
are summarizing the episode number one
we're talking about 2023 YouTube Transit
predictions which one do you like best
which one are you going all in on number
one vertical video number two Master the
Eight Second mindset number three start
your video podcast number four Embrace
artificial intelligence number five
adopt a media company mindset number six
live streaming is here to stay number
seven join the SEO Revival number eight
understand
audiences Beyond demographic information
number nine e-commerce will continue to
grow and we'll do number 10 in just a
second but I do want to encourage you if
you haven't subscribed to think media
podcast subscribe and it means the world
if you rate and review the podcast if
you're on audio uh leaving a review on
Apple it means the world to us if you're
on YouTube drop a comment of where
you're watching from and hit like and
maybe share this podcast with somebody
who wants to learn YouTube in 2023
starter grow their Channel start aside
site hustle and monetize it because
we're going to be bringing you the best
content we've ever brought you this year
and we're so excited for it but number
10 is invest in the skill of
Storytelling in a 2023 world and a lot
of experts agree the creators and
business owners and entrepreneurs that
win when it comes to creating content
are going to master the skill of
Storytelling whether it's knowing how to
tell a story in a YouTube short whether
it's knowing how to tell a story or hook
the viewer's attention and how you
structure a live stream whether it's
tying in stories to your or content you
may have heard it said that facts tell
but stories sell sometimes we can be too
feature driven in our content we're
talking about a lot of facts when what
would really power up our content and
make the connection is telling a story
sometimes all we do is communicate facts
and information when sometimes you can
lose the viewer's attention if you tell
a story however people connect with
stories and if you want someone to do
more than just stop by your channel and
engage on a surface level but actually
connect with you mastering the art of
weaving in stories your story
illustrative stories into your content
will help power up your content that is
a 25 part Series in and of itself but
that was my number 10 and a lot of
experts agreed on that as well the
content that understands storytelling is
going to outperform the content that
does it in a
2023 world
foreign